[Music]
hi everyone it's zack from gsc game
world
it has been several days since the
gameplay reveal of stalker 2.
our game now has a subtitle heart of
chernobyl and the release date of april
28 2022
by the way the pre-orders are opened for
both pc and xbox
you're obviously here willing to learn
more so here are several details about
stalker 2
heart of chernobyl you probably didn't
know yet so let's dive
a little bit deeper in our trailer
this section of the trailer is a
bandit's gunfight on the chemical plant
you can see the actual in-game
animations of picking up the weapons and
installing modifications
on the go
the thing is you can notice the teaser
of a new faction
we are not showing the exact moment
right now because we wonder if you can
discover it yourself
you may actually recognize the exact
location on the swamps
if you played stalker clear sky you may
remember this place
the time did the job but the tower is
definitely still there
also in this scene you can see a brand
new detector skiff is using for the
artifact hunt
because of its form it's called gilca
which actually means a branch in the
ukrainian
the artifact skip is going to collect is
called jelly
in game it recovers your stamina moving
to the dancing man scene
before you ask it yes there will be a
lot of characters with an interesting
fate in the zone
his hideout is located in chernobyl too
that's a town not so far from pre-bet
you have seen in the gameplay teaser
[Music]
the campfires a small isle of safety in
the unwelcoming zone
a place where you can finally have a
little rest before another foray
you have seen the campfire during the
first trailer in the rookie village
of course it wasn't the only one
the zone is full of dangers and mutants
the monsters are the result of the
numerous experiments we are not ready to
show you all of them
so let's stick to the old good
bloodsucker for now
[ __ ]
in this rooftop scene we are truly proud
with the quality of the animations
we made a small behind the scenes video
from our motion capture studio
the phase photogrammetry process makes
the final result as close to the reality
as possible
the gauss gun you're seeing in this
section is one of the most powerful
weapons from the arsenal
moving to the final thing for today the
man at the end of the trailer is sergey
grigarowicz the creator of the stalker
series
thanks for joining us today we can't
wait for the moment when the time comes
to enter the zone on april 28 2022